i
[Aplausos]
a cuántos de ustedes les encantaría
despertarse un día con una idea
increíble que tenga todo el potencial
para cambiar el mundo en un aspecto que
para ustedes sea realmente importante
creo que a todos no pero si nos
detenemos un momento podemos darnos
cuenta de qué es lo que está pasando en
realidad y es que nos hemos acostumbrado
a ver como todo pasa incluso cosas que
nos molestan por ejemplo nos quejamos de
la situación política de nuestro país y
ni siquiera sabemos de qué se trata muy
bien nos quejamos de que existen tantos
problemas de salud y ni siquiera tenemos
buenos hábitos alimenticios también nos
quejamos de la desigualdad económica que
existe en el mundo y muchos de nosotros
nunca hemos hecho un voluntariado en
nuestras vidas
bueno
todo empezó porque cuando llegó el
momento de decidir qué quería ser de
grande
tuve una corazonada y además sonaba
también diseñadora profesional con
mención en diseño gráfico y comunicación
visual suena bien no
pero al final no tenía idea todo lo que
podía llegar a hacer con esta profesión
bueno en este camino me encontré con una
realidad que sinceramente no era muy
alentador ya que veía como muchas ideas
que tenían todo el potencial se quedaban
atrapadas en las aulas de clase y fue
allí cuando me decidí romper
completamente con este patrón
bueno en este camino también me encontré
con una tendencia conocida como el
diseño social con la cual me involucre
tuve mucho que aprender para que
finalmente puede aterrizar lo en un
proyecto mi proyecto que es mi propuesta
tal vez no para cambiar el mundo pero sí
para cambiar una realidad una realidad
que para mí es muy importante y esta es
la seguridad de los niños en las vías de
mi país
esto es vi amiguitos pero bueno
espero que se pregunten qué es el diseño
social porque les voy a contar
para esto voy a tomar las palabras de la
autora argentina maría ledesma que
menciona que todo diseño es social
porque cumple una función sin embargo el
diseño social es la búsqueda de
voluntaria para ayudar a la humanidad o
bien a los grupos vulnerables y esto fue
lo que realmente a mí me apasiona
en el mundo existen muchos ejemplos de
cosas increíbles que se han creado
tenemos por ejemplo el astro que es un
filtro personal para tomar agua de qué
sirve para ser utilizado en crisis
humanitarias
es una idea increíble no otro ejemplo
que puedo darles es el hamlet son que
esta iniciativa fue creada
con la finalidad de sacar a las personas
que no tienen hogar de las calles a
través de sus caligrafías se crearon
tipografías que pueden ser compradas
tanto por nosotros cualquiera cualquier
persona como para empresas grandes y de
esta manera con estos con estos recursos
ayudar a salir de las calles de estas
personas
son ideas increíbles que se han hecho en
el mundo y esto nos demuestra como el
diseño es una herramienta muy poderosa
para que podamos no solo comunicar sino
también para generar una reflexión una
acción a partir de las personas como
nosotros porque somos los verdaderos
agentes de cambio
en este camino
con esta idea en mi cabeza me encontré
con estas cifras realmente alarmantes ya
que según la organización mundial de la
salud cada 4 minutos un niño muere
prematuramente en alguna carretera del
mundo el ecuador fue el segundo país con
mayor índice de mortalidad en américa
latina donde el 36 por ciento de esta
población eran menores de 19 años lo que
representó la primera causa de muerte en
los niños de 5 a 9 años
con esto
con la ayuda de especialistas colegas
amigos y familiares descubrí que una de
las principales causas y la que tal vez
puede representar la más importante es
la falta de educación vial ya que a
pesar de estar contemplada en la ley
ésta no ha sido implementada en todos
los ciclos de la educación
así nació esto y amiguitos
el propósito de este proyecto es generar
un cambio positivo en el comportamiento
de todos nosotros porque todos nosotros
somos los actores de nuestra cultura
vial empezando desde la etapa inicial
este material pudo ser posible gracias a
la ayuda de muchas otras disciplinas
como la psicología la pedagogía y
obviamente la educación vial y esto
permitió que el este material cumpla su
objetivo y es llegar a transmitir el
mensaje a estos usuarios tan importantes
tan hermosos que son los huevos
este proyecto como pueden ver es muy
ambicioso porque pretende cambiarnos a
todos nosotros en nuestro comportamiento
porque necesitamos que no sólo tengamos
en cuenta el respeto nuestra vida sino a
la vida del otro
y es algo en lo que aún me encuentro
trabajando para hacer que esto sea
posible
y bueno como pueden ver el diseño me
ayudó a generar este cambio que estoy
segura que con la ayuda de
organizaciones civiles con la ayuda de
la empresa privada
con las instituciones públicas y
obviamente de ustedes vamos a lograr
generar este cambio ahora
si yo pude encontrar el canal para dar
esta iniciativa imagínense todo lo que
podemos hacer si todos nosotros nos
unimos
pero considero que para que logremos
este cambio el primer paso es que
dejemos de ser espectadores y que juntos
formemos parte del cambio muchas gracias
[Aplausos]